Cómo se pueden analizar estos hechos en
medio de la estrategia de paz total de
Petro esto al tiempo que la fundación
ideas para la paz destacó que los
homicidios Solo han descendido un 8%
desde que el mandatario asumió el cargo
y que es una cifra que pues no es
suficiente
Valentina buenas noches para ti y para
todos los que nos escuchan el día de hoy
Bueno frente a lo que mencionas
la la iniciativa del presidente Petro de
la paz total y el acercamiento con
diferentes grupos fue muy positivo y
abre un espectro de Esperanza importante
para tratar de reducir los niveles de
violencia en el país pero no podemos
esperar que se reduzcan los homicidios
de manera inmediata los grupos con los
que se ha empezado a entablar algún tipo
de conversación real es el eln y según
informó el presidente en el día de hoy
vaya si no estoy mal es que se están
adelantando también con un grupo de
jóvenes de una organización
delincuencial en Buenaventura pero más
allá de eso no hay acercamientos
concretos por lo tanto el contexto de
violencia sigue algunos grupos como el
frente Jaime Martínez del Comando
coordinador de occidente ha expresado su
voluntad de negociar o de acogerse a esa
Paz total pero no hay nada concreto y
mientras no haya nada concreto no
podemos esperar una reducción de
violencia por parte de esos grupos
bueno justamente usted lo estaba
mencionando esta disminución de
homicidios es una prioridad para el
mandatario por ejemplo en la ciudad de
Buenaventura en el Pacífico colombiano
una de las más golpeadas por la
violencia en el país pues lleva 80 días
sin registrar homicidios pero en
ciudades del Caribe han subido en un 23%
que se puede analizar de esta
desigualdad
Pues que los homicidios no responden
únicamente al contexto de violencia
asociado al conflicto armado o a la
violencia y a los a las afectaciones al
orden público ocasionado por estos
grupos delincuenciales los homicidios
tienen una
motivación una causa que va más allá de
la existencia de estos grupos por lo
tanto no podemos asociar las iniciativas
de paz total con reducción inmediata a
domicilios y en diferentes regiones hay
diferentes actores con diferentes
dinámicas y por eso en el Caribe la
dinámica es diferente a lo que sucede en
Buenaventura o lo que sucede en Cali o
lo que sucede en Bogotá o en el sur del
país y más aún cuando hay muchos grupos
que operan en diferentes partes y hay
una disputa territorial entre cada uno
de ellos bueno otro tema que llama la
atención es el aumento de asesinatos de
líderes ambientales ellos que defienden
la tierra que suele suele estar en la
mira de los actores ilícitos que nos
dice esta cifra
pues es que es un reto enorme para el
gobierno del presidente Petro lograr
reducir la violencia contra todo tipo de
líderes y más aún con líderes
ambientales que ha sido una de las
banderas de su campaña de su gobierno y
es un reto que el presidente ha tratado
de empezar a a lidiar pero que todavía
le hace falta mucho poder
operacionalizar la protección de cada
uno de estos líderes en diferentes
partes del país porque nuevamente las
afectaciones a cada uno de los líderes
en cada una de las regiones varía y la
seguridad de ellos es una prioridad
frente a lo cual diferentes gobiernos no
solamente el actual sino diferentes
gobiernos han tratado de incidir y
desafortunadamente no lo han logrado
hacer de manera satisfactoria